think about it that specifically
dangerous things carefully that's such a
place where kids learn oh yeah that is
the only place they learned that's where
everyone learns everything when you're
doing dangerous things carefully man
that's where you learn when you see your
three-year-old daughter climbing up the
monkey bars our daughter used to do that
in our backyard you know and she was
three in the monkey bars were old eight
feet high she liked to go right to the
top and climb across them it's like
we're watching out the back window
thinking but what do you do we you want
around there be careful there's a bit of
malevolence in that oh my daughter is
worrying me I'll go out there and take
care of her about startle er then she'll
fall well that'll fix her she won't do
that again she won't make me nervous
it's like you gotta watch those things
man right it's not about them it's about
you yes that's for sure that's what you
got to ask yourself am I taking care of
my child or am I just afraid to be
afraid for them mm-hmm
you